celebrate the summer with some patriotic
rubber ducks that you can flow in your
4th of July
inflatable cooler because it's episode
42 of loop watch sounds on your iPhone
with this equalizer phone case and
transform your homework into something
that's more than meets the eye with one
of these transformer pens for a
different kind of transformation turn
your bottles into lamps with
rechargeable lights shaped like quartz
then use this smart cub to figure out
where all those empty bottles came from
the vessel recognizes and tracks
everything you drink including caffeine
levels nutritional values and it can
even distinguish between brands or just
play with your drinks by shooting some
hoops then pack your cookies that taste
like cupcakes inside a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich storage pocket for a
no-mess friend play with blob and flow
light-up pets that plug in by a USB and
respond with different light sequences
depending on the touch or just use
emergency googly eyes to bring anything
inanimate to life for something life
less decorate with this unicorn head
plaque and display it next to your
preserved sheep heart
after completing the required operating
course you could purchase your own fly
board that can rocket you 45 feet out of
the water and finally help you swim like
a dolphin for something big but not
quite as expensive you can sell the
skies in this giant 3d pirate ship kite
or win the World Cup of giants with this
huge soccer ball
kick back and let it drone catch the
action with air dog an auto follow air
drone that works with a GoPro camera
just attach a small waterproof
programmable tracker called the air
leash and the quadcopter will follow
your coordinates wherever you go check
in on your fridge new fridge pets and
sit down for a snack of canned dragon
and candy sushi while you read your
paper later a service from the newspaper
Club that prints your desired articles
from the internet into a physical
newspaper and sends it to you via snail
mail it's currently only available in
the UK but they plan to expand to other
areas soon conquer new territory with
this bow and arrow that shoots
marshmallows
and a 14 in one survival watch that
includes a compass bottle opener
firestarter whistle and signaling mirror
make sure everyone feels your presence
with my bell
the first customizable digital horn and
light for bikes each one can hold two
digital sound files chosen by the user
and pre-selected LED lighting patterns
then make a rainbow with some sunlight
and crystals using this standing rainbow
maker and create 3d drawings with Creole
pop unlike other 3d pens this is the
world's first to use cool ink or photo
polymers and doesn't contain any heated
parts or melting plastic the inks come
in a variety of colors elasticity and
some are even magnetic now for those of
age go aerate some wine with a bendy
straw while you sort out your emotions
by stuffing them into a kimochi motion
doll and as always thanks for watching
you